the United States is continuing to make
substantial progress in our war against
the virus we grieve it every precious
life that has been lost to the invisible
enemy but through the darkness we can
see the rays of light we see that tunnel
and at the end of that tunnel we see
light we're starting to see it more than
ever before we've held our rate the
numbers everything we've done we've been
very very strong on it and very powerful
on it you look at what's happening in
other countries Spain Italy United
Kingdom we're working with them we're
trying to help them especially with
ventilators they've been calling a lot
they need ventilators so badly 15% of
counties within the United States have
zero cases and many counties within the
United States have a very small number
of cases large sections of our country
are really looking at other sections and
saying wow that looks bad but they don't
have the problem I salute the American
people for following our guidelines on
social distancing even you people it's
so different looking out there when I
look at you their devotion your devotion
is saving lives
today I'm instructing my administration
to halt funding of the World Health
Organization while a review is conducted
to assess the World Health
Organization's role in severely
mismanaging and covering up the spread
of the corona virus everybody knows
what's going on there American taxpayers
provide between 400 million and 500
million dollars per year to the
w-h-o in contrast China contributes
roughly 40 million dollars a year and
even less as the organization's leading
sponsor the United States has a duty to
insist on full accountability one of the
most dangerous and costly decisions from
the WHL was its disastrous decision to
oppose
travel restrictions from China and other
nations they were very much opposed to
what we did fortunately I was not
convinced and suspended travel from
China saving untold numbers of lives
thousands and thousands of people would
have died had other nations likewise
suspended travel from China countless
more lives would have been saved instead
look at the rest of the world look at
parts of Europe other nations and
regions who follow w-h-o guidelines and
kept their borders open to China
accelerated the pandemic all around the
world many countries said we're going to
listen to the w-h-o and they have
problems the likes of which they cannot
believe nobody can believe the decision
of other major countries to keep travel
open was one of the great tragedies and
missed opportunities from the early days
the whe OS attack on travel restrictions
put political correctness above
life-saving measures travel bans worked
for the same reason that quarantine work
pandemics depend on human to human
transmission border control is
fundamental to virus control since its
establishment in 1948 the American
people have generously supported the
World Health Organization to provide
better health outcomes for the world and
most importantly to help prevent global
health crises with the outbreak of the
kovat 19 pandemic we have deep concerns
whether America's generosity has been
put to the best use possible the reality
is that the w-h-o fail to adequately
obtain vet and share information in a
timely and transparent fashion the world
depends on the w-h-o to work with
countries to ensure that accurate
information about international health
threats is shared in a timely manner and
if it's not to independently tell the
world
about what is happening the w-h-o failed
in this basic duty and must be held
accountable it's time after all of these
decades the w-h-o failed to investigate
credible reports from sources in Wuhan
that conflicted directly with the
Chinese government's official accounts
there was credible information to
suspect human-to-human transmission in
December 2019 which should have spurred
the w-h-o to investigate and investigate
immediately through the middle of
January it paired it and publicly
endorsed the idea that there was not
human to human transmission happening
despite reports and clear evidence to
the contrary that delays the w-h-o
experience in declaring a public health
emergency cost valuable time tremendous
amounts of time more time was lost in
the delay it took to get a team of
international experts in to examine the
outbreak which we wanted to do which
they should have done the inability of
the w-h-o to obtain virus samples to
this date has deprived the scientific
community of essential data new data
that emerges across the world when a
daily basis points to the unreliability
of the initial reports and the world
received all sorts of false information
about transmission and mortality the
silence of the w-h-o on the
disappearance of scientific researchers
and doctors and our new restrictions on
the sharing of research into the origins
of kovat 19 in the country of origin is
deeply concerning especially when we put
up by far the largest amount of money
not even close
had the w-h-o done its job to get
medical experts into china to
objectively
assess the situation on the ground and
to call out China's lack of transparency
the outbreak could have been contained
at its source
with very little death very little death
and certainly very little death by
comparison this would have saved
thousands of lives and avoided worldwide
economic damage instead the w-h-o
willingly took China's assurances to
face value and they took it just at face
value and defended the actions of the
Chinese government even praising China
for its so-called
transparency I don't think so